Yo c'est Cyrus, et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
du coup de Phil'.
"Agis de telle sorte que la maxime de ta volonté puisse être érigée en loi universelle".
Alors si tu te demandes qui est Maxime,
je te conseille vivement de regarder cette vidéo sur l'impératif catégorique de Kant.
Kant c'est un philosophe allemand qui est ouf !
Genre tous les profs de philo le disent: il y a un avant Kant et un après Kant.
Le mec il est un petit peu bizarre hein. Il a vécu toute sa vie au même endroit
et c'est pas Berlin ou Francfort nan c'est Koenigsberg hein,
genre un endroit hyper paumé !
Et Kant il est aussi mort puceau !
Alors quand tu meurs jeune bah voilà ça va, voilà, tant pis.
Mais quand tu meurs à 80 ans... 80 ans !
Alors avant qu'on rentre dans sa philosophie, j'aimerais juste qu'on s'imagine deux secondes
la taille de ses couilles quand même !
Il a traité pas mal de questions fondamentales sur la raison théorique pure
comme par exemple: comment peuvent naître les sciences ?
Question archi-badass !
Mais il a aussi traité de la raison pratique.
Ce qui est en gros la morale.
Et c'est ce qu'on va voir ensemble !
En fait il se rend compte qu'on peut expliquer nos valeurs ou les valeurs d'une société
en fonction des causes et des effets.
Mais on peut pas expliquer pourquoi quelqu'un va adhérer à ces valeurs là.
Parce que c'est quand même quelque chose de super fort d'adhérer à des valeurs.
C'est: tu t'imposes une conduite à toi-même, et en plus on le fait hyper naturellement.
Cette décision pour Kant elle nous vient de notre bonne volonté.
En gros si je prends ma volonté, et bien j'ai d'un côté cette bonne volonté,
et de l'autre il y a nos inclinations, nos désirs, nos humeurs, qui subissent le monde extérieur.
Et la bonne volonté pour Kant elle est autonome.
Ça veut dire qu'elle se donne sa propre loi.
On a l'habitude de dire qu'obéir aux devoirs, c'est perdre sa liberté.
Mais pour Kant c'est justement l'inverse !
Parce que vu que la bonne volonté, elle se donne sa propre loi, c'est la liberté elle-même.
Alors que dans nos humeurs et nos sentiments, il n'y a pas de liberté.
Coupable !
Ha bah nan, en fait, j'ai envie d'aller en prison.
Voilà, donc j'suis libre.
C'est par là c'est ça ?
Enorme, énorme. Merci.
Pour Kant nos actions répondent à deux types d'impératif.
On a, dans un premier temps, l'impératif catégorique.
L'impératif catégorique c'est celui qui va poser une action comme nécessaire et inconditionnelle.
Et ça se pose "a priori", c'est-à-dire avant toute expérience.
De quoi que ce soit.
Avant tout ce qui va dépendre du monde sensible.
En gros ça équivaut à "je dois car je dois".
Quoi qu'il arrive.
Quelques soient les conséquences.
Et c'est pour ça que c'est "a priori".
Et donc la seule chose qui va déterminer mon action, c'est la morale.
Or, vu que c'est "a priori", et ben ça peut mener à des conséquences complètement pourries.
Mais Kant il s'en fout, et il dira que ce qui importe c'est que la conséquence de tes actions
a un caractère moral.
Par exemple pour Kant, c'est pour ça qu'il faut toujours dire la vérité, quelque soit la situation.
Ce qui explique en partie pourquoi il est mort puceau.
Ben moi je veux un truc sérieux quoi. Et toi ?
Ooh moi je cherche pas du tout un truc sérieux nan. Nan nan moi je suis juste là pour baiser.
D'ailleurs t'as senti la caisse que j'ai lâché tout à l'heure ?
J'ai lâché une super grosse caisse. On a parlé de mon double pénis ?
Ou pire
Il y a des juifs ici ?
Oui bien sûr. Anne tu peux venir s'il-te-plaît ?
Anne ?
Elle arrive.
Dans cette exemple, si on se dit "Oui mais c'est pas moral car les nazis vont tuer Anne Frank",
on prend en compte une donnée empirique donc on sort de l'a priori,
et donc on sort de l'impératif catégorique.
L'impératif catégorique il répond aussi à trois principes:
Le principe d'universalité. C'est la phrase que j'ai dit au tout début.
"Agis de telle sorte que la maxime de ta volonté puisse être érigée en loi universelle"
En fait c'est un peu l'idée de "ne fais pas aux autres ce que t'aimerais pas qu'on te fasse."
Sauf que là c'est plus que l'action en elle-même.
C'est le principe auquel obéit ta volonté qui est à l'origine de l'action.
Genre par exemple c'est pas dire aux nazis où sont les juifs, mais c'est le principe de dire la vérité.
Le principe d'humanité: Il faut traiter les autres toujours comme une fin et jamais comme un moyen.
Principe d'autonomie: La loi morale s'impose à nous, par nous même.
C'est ce que je vous ai expliqué plus tôt.
Bonjour mesdames et messieurs et bienvenue dans le sable show !
Je vous demanderai de jouer le jeu et de faire pause à la fin de cette question pour y répondre dans les commentaires.
Sur cette image, David sauve Émilie d'un incendie.
Selon vous, cet acte relève-t-il de l'impératif catégorique ?
Réponse en fin de vidéo.
Ça c'était pour l'impératif catégorique, mais il y a un autre type d'impératif,
c'est les impératifs hypothétiques.
Les impératifs hypothétiques eux ils arrivent du coup a postériori, c'est-à-dire après les expériences,
après les éléments empiriques.
Donc c'est quand il y a de l'empirique dans ta décision.
Ce qui fait que autant, l'impératif catégorique est inconditionnel,
autant les impératifs hypothétiques sont conditionnels.
En gros c'est "si j'ai tel but, il faut que j'agisse de telle façon".
Genre si j'ai froid, je mettrais un pull.
Ça fait partie des impératifs hypothétiques.
Ben moi je veux un truc sérieux quoi. Et toi ?
Ben ça tombe bien, moi aussi je veux un truc sérieux.
Pour Kant un acte moral c'est un acte qui répond à l'impératif catégorique.
Du coup euh, s'abonner à cette chaîne, ça peut être moral si vous me voyez comme une fin,
et non seulement comme un moyen d'apprendre des trucs et de, je l'espère, passer un bon moment.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
Je vous envoie du love et de la peace.
YALA !
Comme vous avez pu remarquer par rapport aux autres choses qu'on a vu, c'est à des années-lumières
de ce qu'aurait pu penser Machiavel, qui est juste ici.
On aura l'occasion de reparler de la morale, et de voir que la conception kantienne s'oppose par exemple
à celle des utilitaristes.
Le sauvetage de David ne répond pas à un impératif catégorique !
En effet on peut voir que David a un gros paquet, et qu'Emilie est extrêmement attractive.
Au-delà de ça on peut voir un bébé aussi dans le fond de l'image, qui ne sera PAS sauvé par David.
David a donc sauvé Émilie dans le seul but de coucher avec elle.
Il a donc considéré Émilie comme un moyen, et non comme une fin.